este parqueadero a la entrada a la
ciudad de sap orilla se ha convertido en
el lugar soñado de miles y miles de
personas que huyen de ciudades en el sur
de ucrania no sólo de marie paule donde
llegaban más de 130 personas que vivían
de la ciudad sino también de otras
ciudades que están en control de las
fuerzas rusas desde hace ya varias
semanas como melitópol libertad ese es
el caso de tamara este plan a que
llegaron hoy
vicky muy pic y es difícil irse es
difícil y probablemente la mayoría de la
gente no quiera irse por eso es muy
difícil ellos los rusos podemos decirlo
de esta manera son muy abruptos
ellos exigen tarjetas sin auriculares
cigarrillos revisan los teléfonos
revisaron todas mis fotos todos los
chats de telegram y buscaban la bandera
ucraniana o cualquier cosa relacionada
con la simbología ucraniana
en este parqueadero se sigue esperando
que más personas puedan huir de esas
herida de azúcar donde cientos de
personas siguen todavía en esos refugios
subterráneos y están asediadas por esas
fuerzas rusas sin embargo poco a poco
van llegando vehículos privados de
personas que al lugar han logrado huir
de la ciudad y es que no lo pueden hacer
directamente tienen que ir a una ciudad
de verdad es que el poder de las fuerzas
rusas allí ir pasando cada uno de esos
retenes más de 17 del ejército ruso con
las dificultades hasta poder llegar
hasta aquí hay personas que se tardan
incluso tres o cuatro días